CRAIG LABENZ: In
the last episode,
you created a web app in Cloud
Run backed by a Cloud SQL
database.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes.
And it's an app that pulls
developers preferences for tabs
or spaces in their code.
Everything works.
But I'm not sure about
how scalable it is.
CRAIG LABENZ: No one is yet.
That's why we need to
run some load tests.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My favorite tool for
this is a Python library
called Locust.io.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
I've heard of that.
Let's see.
Python3 and pip.
OK.
I'm installing it now.
CRAIG LABENZ: Great.
I also sent you another file
earlier called locustfile.py.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yep.
I have it right here.
What does this file do exactly?
CRAIG LABENZ: It
creates two types
of users, one that views
the homepage and one that
cast votes.
And now with the
weight attribute,
we've told Locust.io to send
five times as many home page
views as votes cast.
Most apps are pretty read heavy.
So I thought that might
mimic your users' behavior.
MARTIN OMANDER: 5 to 1, yeah.
That ratio sounds about right.
CRAIG LABENZ: OK, great.
In that case, you can run
locust-f locustfile.py
to start the process.
MARTIN OMANDER: All righty.
Starting it.
CRAIG LABENZ: Cool.
And the Locust server
is now running.
So if you click on the link it
just printed in your terminal,
we'll be ready to
start the test.
MARTIN OMANDER: All righty.
Open that one.
Ah, OK.
Number of users.
I'll start with 50.
Spawn rate, what's that?
CRAIG LABENZ: The
spawn rate controls
how quickly Locust should
reach full throttle.
So if you enter a
value of 10, Locust
would reach 50 concurrent
users in five seconds.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Cool.
And then for your
URL, I will grab that
from the live URL over
here and paste that in,
and this is neat.
I'm going to release the swarm.
OK.
So it's sending data to the
app if I click here on charts.
Ah, right.
Here I see the
traffic ramping up.
Response times, OK.
Bit of a long response time
right there in the beginning
but then it's plateauing out.
Pretty good response times.
The subsecond response times.
It looks like it's holding
up pretty well, especially
since we deployed
this app to Europe.
And we're running this
test from California.
But we should take
a peek at how things
are running on the server.
Let's see here.
We'll go into Cloud Run.
All right.
So I'm scrolling down here,
checking out the container
memory utilization.
Looks like it's at a
pretty healthy level.
But of course, Cloud
Run is serverless.
So it would add more
resources if they were needed.
So Cloud Run should
really always be healthy.
CRAIG LABENZ: Right.
And to that point, the real
question we're here to answer
is how your database
is holding up.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, OK.
Switching to the database
in the console now.
Going into the poll database.
CPU was very low.
Then we created the database.
So that took a lot of CPU.
Then it was very low
here when it did nothing.
And then we started the
test right around here.
It looks like CPU is still
pretty low even though we're
putting a lot of load on it.
Let's have a look at memory.
Memory usage is holding
steady around 600 megabytes.
And our server has
3.75 gigabytes.
So memory is also healthy.
CRAIG LABENZ: And remember,
since you're not launched yet,
if it shows high
CPU or memory, it
would be very easy to increase
those for your database
while there are still no
users to care about downtime.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, sounds good.
But what if I have
launched my app
and the database is struggling?
What should I do then?
CRAIG LABENZ: I usually follow
a four step plan to ensure
that my apps perform well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
I love ordered lists.
CRAIG LABENZ: First, the
obvious place to start
is optimizing your
actual database queries.
Things like making sure every
column involved in a where
clause has an underlying
database index,
or that frequently run
expensive queries like counts,
are denormalized if possible.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's
great to keep in mind.
But what should I do
if my app is still
slow after optimizing
all of my queries?
CRAIG LABENZ: It's true
that optimization can only
get you so far.
So the second step is to
simply add more CPUs or memory
to your database instance.
This is often the simplest fix.
However, even that
runs into limits.
For example, making your
main database larger
won't necessarily
help an app that
performs well in one hemisphere
but poorly in the other.
And so my third step is
to add read replicas,
potentially in different regions
if your users are global.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
This makes sense so far.
And it sounds like
these steps would
accommodate most applications.
What's the last step?
CRAIG LABENZ: The last step
is to introduce partitioning,
or sharding, to your database.
But you should never
attempt these solutions
until you've exhausted all
of your simpler options.
Because these are the most
complicated to do correctly.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, that
list is really helpful.
My users incessantly
refresh the page
to track which team is
winning tabs or spaces.
So I'm optimistic
about read replicas.
Could we set one up?
CRAIG LABENZ: For sure.
To set up a read replica, click
on your Cloud SQL instance
and then click on the
replicas tab on the left.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Replicas.
Yep.
CRAIG LABENZ: Select
the Create Read Replica
button in the middle.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very nice.
CRAIG LABENZ: And all of these
default values should be good.
So you can press Create.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
CRAIG LABENZ: Now this will
take several minutes to catch up
to your production database.
Now that your replica is ready,
navigate back to your Cloud Run
service and click on
the Edit and Deploy
a New Revision button.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Here's my poll service.
I'm clicking it.
Edit and deploy new version.
All right.
And I'm clicking it.
CRAIG LABENZ: And on that page,
select the Connections tab.
MARTIN OMANDER: Connections.
Very good.
Cloud SQL connections?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah.
Right there, you can
press Add Connection
and select your new replica.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, there's
my poll database replica.
CRAIG LABENZ: And
once you deploy this,
you'll be ready to route
your select queries
to that replica in
your application code
as you see fit.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that sounds excellent.
Do you have any advice
on how to do that,
where to route queries?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yes.
First and foremost,
read replicas
can only receive read
queries, so select statements.
Insert or update queries cannot
go to your read replicas.
They will fail.
And they must go to
the primary database.
Now just be aware if you
write to the main database
and then immediately
trying to read
those same rows
from your replica,
you may not get the latest data.
And in this situation, you must
also send those select queries
to your main database.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I'll work the read replica
into my application code later.
For now, I think
I'm ready to launch.
CRAIG LABENZ: Congratulations.
Your MVP is out the
door and now begins
the long process of adding
new bugs, I mean features.
MARTIN OMANDER: Maybe
you write bugs, Craig.
But I prefer not to.
CRAIG LABENZ: Well, if you
prefer not adding bugs,
then you might want to plan
ahead for your eventual changes
to your database schema.
With a distributed
infrastructure like Cloud Run,
it's critical to keep
database schema updates out
of your application
startup code.
MARTIN OMANDER: Why is that?
CRAIG LABENZ: Well,
some developers
run database schema updates like
creating new tables or columns
as part of their
application launch.
But for example, let's
say the next version
of your application
needs a country table.
If this table is created by
your framework when it starts,
multiple Cloud Run instances
could simultaneously
detect that the table
is missing and attempt
to create and populate it.
Some of those queries
could fail or you
could end up with
a countries table
full of duplicate records.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
I usually run all of
my database schema
changes a separate
Cloud build step
when I build my new container.
CRAIG LABENZ: Perfect.
That's definitely the
right way to handle it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
I feel a lot more confident
about pairing Cloud SQL
and Cloud Run now.
Let's see if I can remember
all of the important tips.
First, I load test and profile
my app to measure performance.
As needed, I apply the
optimization steps.
Second, to avoid
conflict I make sure
that my database
scheme updates don't
run on application startup.
CRAIG LABENZ: That's it.
With those steps,
Cloud Run and Cloud SQL
can be a great pairing like
cheese and wine or peas
and carrots.
Or dare I say, like
tabs and spaces.
MARTIN OMANDER: What?
No.
You don't mix tabs and spaces.
What's wrong with you, Craig?
[MUSIC PLAYING]